what was your question about Matthew 24
yeah so um so it's it's a Rapture
question because I know that um see the
dispensation I just knew it didn't I say
you reading your dispensationalism into
it yeah Rapture when does The Rapture
happen um so I mean I I know I know what
it speaks about in first Thessalonians
but so when does it
happen um so that's the thing so there's
seven years in the middle of seven years
at the end of seven years well so I I I
I believe that it's a pre-tribulation
Rapture um I'll give you $10 million to
show me in New Testament where it says
there's a tribulation of seven years no
no no yeah I don't I don't I don't think
there's a tribul I don't think there's a
seven-year tribulation I think how long
is it uh well I think there's gonna
be how long is
tribulation so I I think there is I
think there's going to be three and a
half years the last well the last three
and a half is the worst that it's ever
been on the earth okay so now notied
what you did you just contradict
yourself you said last three and a half
which means there's a first three and a
half that's seven years but it doesn't
say it doesn't say there's a there's a
yeah nothing in New Testament right for
seven years right so number one there's
nothing about seven years in the New
Testament that is a misapplication
misunderstanding of Daniel 9:27 right
number two let's go with your view let's
just assume you're right there the
Rapture happens before the tribulation
right according to you we're going to
say three and a half years according to
1 Thessalon 4 what you just
read if the rapture happens before the
tribulation there's a resurrection of
Believers and then there'll be a
transformation of believers who are on
earth so if I'm alive and your life were
transformed those who died in Christ
they'll be raised right their bodies be
raised and then we're going to meet the
Lord in the air right right but then you
have a problem with Revelation 20
because Revelation 20 says that the
resurrection of Believers takes place at
the start of Jesus's Thousand-Year Reign
but if we go with your interpretation
that should have been the second
Resurrection because you just said
there's a prior resurrection of
Believers before the tribulation but
Revelation 20 20 Revelation 24-6 says
that those who died in Christ they'll be
raised at the start of the Thousand-Year
Reign and that's the first resurrection
so how can you have one prior to that
Revelation 20:
4-6 yeah um I I don't exactly know I
only I only know about um you know why
you bought into dispensationalism it's
not biblical it's a teaching about 200
years old unheard of in church history
gotcha so what you're doing you're
coming under influence of
dispensationalist teachers these are bad
arguments I used to believe it because
like you I
was raised among Baptist and they taught
that but then as I examined because
Proverbs 1817 States the first to
present his case seems right until his
neighbor comes and questions him so they
they seemed right they sounded right but
then until I heard other viewpoints and
I saw this teaching has no basis in
scripture and has no basis in early
church history in fact do you know when
if we go with your reading in Matthew 24
do you know when Jesus gathers his
elect when is he when does he gather
when does he gathers them after the
tribulation not before it Matthew 24
29-31 go to Matthew 2429 to
31 so if I go with Jesus the elect are
gathered after the tribulation not
before it Matthew 24 29-31 that's if I
go with your reading of Matthew 24
that's referring to Jesus's return
physically and The Rebirth of Israel as
a nation 1948 too many assumptions but
for argument sake I'm gonna assume that
so read Matthew 24 29:31 when does our
Lord gather his elect
Believers after the tribulation
immediately after the anguish of those
days the sun will be darkened the moon
will give says anguish it's actually the
word tribulation
okay um this and I'm actually reading
the
NLT yep okay actually the word
tribulation it's immediately after the
tribulation of those days okay uh the
sun will be dark and the moon will give
no light the Stars will fall from the
sky and the powers in the heavens will
be shaken and then at last the sign that
the son of man is coming will appear in
the heavens and there will be deep
mourning among all the peoples of the
earth and they will see the son of man
coming on the Clouds Of Heaven with
power and great Glory
and he will send out his angels with the
mighty blast of a trumpet and they will
gather his chosen ones from all over the
world from the that's right so there you
go so stop reading these passages as a
dispensationalist ask the Holy Spirit
now to illuminate you read them a
fresh and instead of seeing things in
the passage that are not there like the
Fig Tree means the rebirth of Israel as
a nation that's not what Matthew 24 says
or there's going to be the Rapture
before the tribulation where does the
New Testament say that in fact if I read
1 Thessalonians 4 and 5 together as a
unit 1 Thessalonians chapter 4 1318 and
5 verses 1 to 10 if you read as a unit
because there are no chapter divisions
do you know when the body of Believers
will be caught up to meet the Lord in
the air and by the way did you notice it
says air it doesn't say
heaven yeah it says uh it says air it
says it's a I guess in the in the in the
air meaning the sky above when the Lord
descends not in heaven but if you
actually read 1 Thessalonians 41318 and
stop and continue to chapter 5 because
Paul continues the theme in chapter 5 it
says this will
happen when the day of the Lord comes
like a thief in the night but according
to Second Peter chapter 3 the day of the
Lord that comes like a thief of knif is
when the Lord comes down to destroy the
Earth by fire here let me show you open
up your Bible 1 Thessalonians chapter
4 so I used to read them the way you did
because you're under the influence of of
specific teachers but you got to broaden
your perspective because Proverbs 18:17
States the first to present his case
seems right until his neighbor comes and
questions him so number one you need to
broaden your perspective hear multiple
voices on how Christ will return and
number two this teaching of
dispensationalism it's recent in history
it's about 200 years old it's unheard of
in the early church unheard of right you
won't find it so that doesn't mean it's
wrong but it means that you're going to
have to do a very thorough
solid ex aesus of scripture that's
overwhelmingly supportive of your view
otherwise it's simply a tradition of men
now if go to first Thessalonians 4 what
you're going to do because you got the
new new living transl you don't have any
other translation besides that I I I
actually have the Bible Hub app so I can
go to any
translation yeah New Living Translation
has its pros and cons uh read new King
James version if you like new King James
okay read you're going to do 1
Thessalonians 4 13 to18 and then when
you're done you're going to go to
chapter 5 immediately okay first
Thessalonians chapter 4 verses
1318 okay uh but I do not want you to be
ignorant Brethren concerning those who
have fallen asleep lest you sorrow as
others who have no hope for if we
believe that Jesus died and rose again
even so God will bring him bring with
him those who sleep in Jesus for this we
say to you by the word of the Lord that
we who are alive and remain until the
coming of the Lord will by no means
precede those who are asleep for the
Lord himself will descend from heaven
with a shout with the voice of an
archangel and with the trumpet of God
and the dead in Christ will rise first
now notice the dead in Christ will rise
right that's right when he comes down
this is the rapture right okay keep
going uh then we who are alive and
remain shall be caught up together with
them in the clouds to meet the Lord in
the air and thus we shall always be with
the Lord therefore Comfort one another
with these words now go right into
chapter 5 there were no chapter Visions
in the original Greek chapter 5 verses
one to two what does he
mention the day of the Lord well read it
don't give me the but concerning the
times and the seasons Brethren
concerning times and seasons of
what uh what he just mentioned right
right what he just mentioned he said now
concerning the times and seasons of this
event that the Lord will come down
with the voice of an archangel and the
trumpet of God and the dead in Christ
will that the times and season of this
event look what he says about it you
have no need that I should write to you
for you yourselves know perfectly that
the day of the Lord so comes as a thief
in the night for when they say peace and
safety then sudden destruction comes
upon them as labor pains upon a pregnant
woman and they shall not Escape you're
not escaped so this event where the Lord
comes down and the dead in Christ will
rise first us and we will meet them in
the air is is called called the day of
the Lord that comes like a thief in the
night right right go to Second Peter
3:10 see what day this is the day of the
Lord that comes like a thief when will
that happen and what happens when that
day arrives second Peter 3:10 but the
day of the Lord will come as a thief in
the night in which the heavens will pass
away with a great noise and the elements
will melt with fervent heat both the
earth and the works that are in it will
be burned up but according to
dispensationalism that doesn't take
place until after the thousand year
reign of Christ right right because when
the Lord comes down he's going to reain
on Earth for a thousand years right
right and then after the thousand years
he's going to Usher a new Heaven to
Earth so this Earth will be purged by
fire correct right but even let's say
some would say no no when the Lord comes
down even before the Thousand-Year Reign
he'll Purge the world of the evildoers
by fire Everlasting destruction okay but
that happens after the tribulation right
right and when that happen that's the
day of the Lord that comes like a thief
in the
night second Peter 3:10 right so this is
the day of the Lord that comes like a
thief when he comes down to destroy the
elements by
fire are you seeing it you're second
Peter 3:10 yeah so the day of the Lord
that comes like a thief is when the Lord
comes down to destroy the elements by
fire right that's right
does that happen before or after the
tribulation after but wait according to
Paul that's when the dead in Christ will
be raised first and we will be caught up
to meet them in the air that's the same
day so how can it be before the Lord
destroys Elements by
fire yeah I um I have not and I've heard
I've heard mix views on both but again I
I really was interested in your thoughts
on it because I know you're you know
you're your your very thorough with your
Bible teaching and so I wanted to I
wanted to get your thoughts on it
because I've been study I me I've heard
a lot about the Rapture and stuff and uh
then there's a lot of there's a lot of
stuff going on right now with um on you
know Messiah you know uh Rock Island
books that did a whole thing on um you
know the Rapture and so there's a lot of
there's a lot of people talking about it
but but now let me give you another
element you remember 1 Thessalonians
41318 says and those who are dead in
Christ they'll be raised first right
right and then we'll be caught up to
meet them in the
air right first Thessalonians 4 right
that's what it said yep okay let me tell
you when the dead in Christ will be
raised go to Revelation 20 verses
1-6 if the Bible doesn't contradict
itself and it doesn't there is no dead
in Christ being raised before the
tribulation uh then I saw an angel
coming down from heaven having the key
to the bottomless pit and a great chain
in his hand he laid hold of the dragon
that Serpent of old who is the devil and
Satan and bound him for a thousand years
and he cast him upon the upon the
bottomless pit and shut him up and set a
seal on him so that he should deceive
the Nations no more to the Thousand
Years so you can understand what you're
reading slowly so okay so he's goingon
to be bound up a thousand years in the
abyss the bottomless pit keep
going um and uh so that he should
deceive the Nations no more till the
thousand years were finished but after
these things he must be released for a
little while and I saw Thrones and they
sat on them and judgment was committed
to them then I saw the souls of those
who had been beheaded for their witness
to Jesus and for the word of God who had
not worshiped the Beast or his image and
had not received his mark on their
foreheads or on their hands and they
lived and reigned with Christ for a
thousand
years but the but the rest of the Dead
did not live again until the thousand
years were finished this is the first
resurrection blessed and holy is he who
has part in the first resurrection over
such the second death has no power
but they shall be Priests of God and of
Christ and shall reign with him a
thousand years when does the first
resurrection take place according to
that
um after the after the thousand- year
reign no not after no it says but the
rest of the Dead will not live again
until the thousand years were finished
this is the first when did the first
resurrection take place reread it that's
why I say you're reading too fast and
you don't understand what you're reading
so it's before it's before the the
thousand year reign at the start of the
thousand year end because they are
raised to reign with him for a thousand
years right and that's and that's after
tribulation so the Thousand Years begin
before the tribulation no no no the
thousand years is after Tri after the
tribulation okay so you answered your
question so when does the resurrection
of Believers take place the resurrection
of those who have died in Christ takes
place when the Lord comes to Reign for a
thousand years right but your view says
the dead in Christ were raised before
the tribulation before Christ comes down
to Reign for a thousand
years I got you yeah and I like I said
I've heard both views and I I wasn't I I
wasn't exactly sure so I wanted to get
your thoughts on on uh what you thought
so what you need to do is unlearn the
dispensational interpretation of
scripture and relearn what the
scriptures teach aresh too many
assumptions too many passages out of
context that are brought together in a
way that
not clear and it's not accurate and
faithful to scripture not saying you
from the people that you're learning
from right